où
[Musique]
oh
la pression venant de la chine est forte
le président lui même en a fait une
priorité un accord de libre-échange avec
le canada mais qu'est ce qu'on peut y
gagner
[Musique]
selon une étude du conseil d'affaires
canada chine ont traité de libre échange
entre les deux pays se traduirait par m
5000 emplois de plus au canada d'ici
2030 et des exportations annuelles vers
la chine qui passerelle 21 milliards à
plus de 28 milliards avec son marché
d'un milliard 400 millions personnes
la chine présente un potentiel énorme là
bas les salaires augmentent et la classe
moyenne s'agrandit et le canada pourrait
en profiter
une occasion d'affaires ou un cadeau
empoisonné
certains craignent que notre secteur
manufacturier et coop
comment concurrencer des entreprises
chinoises aux normes de travail et
environnementales - ennemi
d'autres s'inquiètent que les chinois
s'accaparent les technologies les idées
développées ici au canada
les américains il on penserait quoi est
ce le bon moment de flirter avec les
chinois alors qu'on tente de renégocier
l'alena
l'idée pourrait déplaire à dompter
[Musique]
on
si je serai plus d'eau se lance dans la
négociation de traités
il pourrait bien prendre son temps et
jouer de prudence comme l'a dit
confucius une petite impatience win un
grand projet
[Musique]